whoa 45 pending challenges so many
people so many people let's play a
random sub it should say in Zen mood if
it doesn't okay it's in Zen mode ooh
15 minutes chefs I'm not sure if this is
rated or underrated or who I'm playing
Ethan okay Casey Kenny lava says oMG
it's me I don't know if I should trust
that let's play d5 let's see what why
this is up to we're gonna see a London
probably so many people play the London
I know the game is maybe longer than
people like but the point is just to
kind of be chill hopefully be
instructive play Queens gambit declines
done with gambling for now I guess I
could have played an elven if I really
wanted to but I don't know the strength
of my opponent to rush to rush involving
c5 it's possible I'm gonna play it
normal maybe I'll play at Cambridge
Springs soaking wet sighs says I find
the slower games easier to follow yeah I
did a survey it's somewhere on my twitch
page let's play C songs
if people want to actually give feedback
I usually don't promote this but I have
it here if you go to a feedback right
here click on this it takes you to a
forum I don't know if you can access it
on mobile but it is interesting to kind
of see what the audience wants when I
should stream should probably put this
as central time but people get the point
okay back to where is it my turn okay
Bishop d3 let's take a pond I had this
other day actually I posted a post of
the video to youtube called the
invincible pawn and it was the same
position opponent started thinking I
should first notice Bishop d3 is a
mistake and this is one of the reasons
why Cambridge Springs is so powerful is
because the most natural thinking was is
not so good as if the bishop takes back
then 94 and I fork the bishop on g5 and
the knight on c3 both with the knight
and the Queen also participates and I
wind up on so it's interesting my
opponent is thinking here
yeah I wouldn't be surprised if like a
lot of the viewers who are watching
right now saw the video on YouTube
if you haven't seen the video is there a
youtube command there should be a
youtube command go to my youtube channel
it's like a I think the second most
recent video Bishop c2
well there's a bishop c2 surprising so
I'm I'm up a pawn but it's kind of
overextended I can play this move Queen
d2 also play b5 let's play b5 just
keeping the option open of before do i
play before immediately
maybe not
just seems unnecessary play Bishop b7
just improving slowly but surely there's
some interesting structure the structure
can emerge from a lot of like Queen's
Gambit positions where like sacks a pond
has the two Center ponds we'll see what
happens do you recommend varying
openings to improve the game or focus on
a few I recommend varying or maybe
switching openings when you're stuck in
a slump
when it's you're having a hard time
improving but in general I would say if
you are looking to improve you should
focus more on like strategy studying
top-level games and end games bit more
than openings but if you do play a
variety of openings it kind of teaches
you a lot more about different
structures
but if you know one opening well then
it's maybe a more effective weapon than
knowing like five different openings
have not so well so there's pros and
cons to both wire end games importance
any game that reaches endgame is decided
in that game any game that reaches
opening at least most games that reach
the opening is not decided in the
opening can i play this move are we
gonna have invincible pawn part two with
c3 coming c3 coming Wow Knight a for c3
pawn is wedged very deep into White's
territory Bishop a6 looming Queen and
rook are the maybe event eventual
victims I initially put my bishop here
to play c5 to breathe fire along the
long diagonal
I guess after c3 Bishop a6 who's Bishop
d3 but that's okay
I play Bishop a6 right away oh but then
takes the bishop defends the night okay
c3 time invincible pawned part two I'm
already thinking Howell I'll design the
thumbnail because the last thumbnail the
pawn was on d3 I had this like zoom
effect it was nice because it was
centralized c3 a bit less centralized
but still magnificent c5 stole an idea
in the position envisioning some line
where I play c5 we trade I take on a3
and then win the bishop because my queen
is still applying pressure but in that
specific line I could lose a rook or two
rooks so I have to be careful
so my one goal for the rest of the game
is to not lose this pawn it spawns my
baby a three trying to remove the
defender of the pawn it's not very nice
this pawn is my baby this pawn is my
babysitter
[Music]
I played Bishop a six-digit D 394
probably doesn't work this is
interesting but then still this oh so
what if I combine ideas play Bishop a6
Bishop d3 we trade bishops and then
Queen b5 and if we trade on b5 then the
Knights trapped kind of night has c5
then we trade again should be fine yeah
let's do that
as after Bishop d3 here here here
I'm ready to play a five so if the Queen
was away I just play a five and I
reinforced the pawn chain
Eric values pawns more than the night
that might be true I'm gonna go out of
my way to defend this pawn this pawn is
I mean it's so valuable I think it's
it's probably as valuable as a minor
piece piece it's probably more valuable
than this Knight
so let's take Queen b5 coming
there's no sneaky Oh Edmund I could take
another pawn oh but then I lose this
pawn but then maybe this pawn could be
invincible but then it's on the edge
Oh white's thinking here considering
this move but it would be bad because I
take the Queen and then the rook
okay Queen b5 so I made sure there's no
stinky Knight b6 move because just 90
xb6
if Knight my knight wasn't here that
night p6 could maybe be a problem in
some line
so yeah I'm not sure what White's doing
here yes there's a there's probably
three options taking the Queen was one
option moving the Queen are defending
the Queen with other two options
but now the knight is kind of trapped
this pawn is surviving still expecting
this move but that'll win a pawn because
I'll take twice on c5 first with the
Knights then with the bishop and then
I'll be ready to take them before
yeah I guess he could sack the night for
the invincible pawn but that I I wind up
with another invincible pawn and then
I'll reinforce it with everything ah
there goes my pawn okay
new invincible pawn I can still name the
title invincible pawn unless this pawn
is somehow lost that would be the worst
let's defend first with a knight worth
of rook maybe with the rook yeah with
the rook works are meant to be behind
invincible pawns so that was somewhat of
a plot twist but that's okay
Wow before this is just what I want if
he takes on c3 I have my third
invincible pawn
such a nice punching a five soon-to-come
building the foundation for my structure
it's like I'm building a skyscraper I
started building from the top and then
building kind of working my way down
that's probably physically impossible in
real life okay 94 is still an idea at
some point I want to win the b3 pond
also I need to guess my opponents rating
I forgot I'm playing in Zen mode I
mentioned it at the beginning of the
game my opponent was a rating of the
other game that I had played like 1600 I
would guess like 16 or 1700 so far maybe
like 16 22 left to say it's probably a
nice year for some people a 5 preventing
me from playing a 5 so I'm left with a
slightly smaller pawn chain than I
wanted but that's ok to make 2 let's
play 94 go for the bishop trade try and
connect the rooks and then maybe in the
future this Knight ever moves I'll have
Knight d2 trying to win this pond
yeah okay so we trade and whites a bit
stuck also the spawns are a bit weak so
maybe I'll just go and win the pawn
bring the other rook in guess Rick a one
could be played a six let's put the rook
here I just want to win the pond I can
potentially attack the pawn with my
other rook and with my Knights so it
should not be difficult to win this pawn
and once I win this phone my a pawn will
have freedom and then I can push the
pawn
hopefully to like a four and then break
through Goldust Tori in the chats shout
outs to Goldust Tori legendary chess
player
I was watching Goldust Tori is a stream
the other night and she was watching
none other than my invincible pawn video
Goldust Tori you're you're in time to
catch invincible pawn part 2 which pawn
was this
I think the started is my be pawn
because originally my D pawn had went to
to c3 and then my be pawn reinforced but
which one is this okay I'm going all the
way back oh that's my C pawn yeah kind
of got confusing because it started like
that and then this came here and that
came here so the pawn has had many file
changes
okay I have a battery on the six rink
the only way to defend the a pond is to
bring the rook to create a defensive
battery but then the straw that breaks
the pawns back is an IP eight by all
these piece emblem 22 98 attacking the
pawn and setting up for the next game I
probably want to take with the rook just
trade all the rooks
and give this one freedom
oh there's ninety five the
counter-attack mmm ninety five not
played weights my pawn can be pushed if
the pawn turns into a queen is it still
invincible I can also play ninety two
here
that's why 92
going after this pawn if Knight takes D
to my pawn continues with its journey
also b3 can't really be defended ooh
trying to make it so I don't have to set
promotes but pushing is probably the
best move oh I have an idea okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna push first pawn is still
invincible threatening me than one
expecting this
there is takes with check actually
there's also that move Wow okay let's
take this pawn hitting the rook also
threatening Nathan - oh this is really
rough for whites not sure how white
defends didn't you have meat oh I had me
I could have Queens but I don't want to
give away my pawn or maybe I should Oh
No
wait how do we define invincibility
so the pawn if the pawned promotes is it
still invincible it just changes it's no
longer a pawn but it still has a soul of
a pawn
I'm not sure this is very philosophical
I guess it was invincible until I Queens
otherwise hurt the rook was gonna take
it and she and the illusion
thanks for the $1 oh man people are so
upset in the chat are a key but are I
Pizza who all I appoint was rated 1138
what did I guess 1622
I guess 1622 oh man
I thought my opponent was plainly
reasonably actually like played pretty
well for the rating give him that maybe
you recognize the danger like Bishop c2
actually was impressive move maybe one
of the best moves his classical rating
is 1623 what oh wow oh that's cool that
I guessed
16:22 that played chess noobs
interesting casing for the letters
okay that's still going on YouTube
YouTube people you guys can debates how
we classify invincible ponds once a
promotes thanks for watching subscribe
like share on Twitter and reddit and
with your friends and I'll see you in
the future
and gold dust story also says hi to
YouTube